It's an image that will go down in
history for the first time since plating
ends and in 1953 and North Korean leader
in this case,
the ruthless dictator can Jong Uhmm
Pacet ports in South Korea to declare
his supposed intentions for peace and
denuclearization.
Now the questions are,
is this really a moments of peace?
What can we expect?
Why does everything seem to suddenly be
going so smoothly?
I mean,
is North Korea really willing to give up
that nuclear bomb?
Well,
it's a view of these are some of the
questions that I'm sure you are all
thinking.
Well,
that's what we look at it.
Shall We?
Okay,
okay.
Humming while walking and even holding
hands toasting and dining together.
This is how we were able to witness the
north and South Korean leaders last
Friday on April the 27th 2018 we're
talking about the latest into Korea.
Summit's in which both countries
committed to seeking a definitive peace
agreements.
Technically,
both careers are still at Wachter
rebuild their relations and pursue the
denuclearization of the Korean
Peninsula.
There's something took place in the
demilitarized zone in the town of Pam
and John in the exact place where the
Korean War armistice was signed.
Okay.
Both the North Korean leader,
Kim Jong and South Korean president moon
giant displays a level of complicity
that would have been very hard to
imagine only a few months ago pictures
from that day.
They are going to go down in history,
and I'm really not exaggerating here.
The scenes that we saw of walks,
handshakes and whispers between the two
leaders,
what ends have been out of place in a
romance movie.
Do you remember the honeymoon?
I promise you we're going to have it.
And you know what,
in a way that was precisely what was
happening.
It was a political courtship between two
leaders who really couldn't be more
different.
On the one hand you have the South
Korean president,
Moon Jan,
a lawyer who specialized in human
rights,
a man of humble origins,
whose parents managed to flee from North
Korea and she was an activist for
democracy during his youth.
Okay.
And on the other hands we have Kim John
and one of the worst tyrants on the
planet's.
He's the omnipresent leader of one of
the most terrible countries that anyone
could possibly imagine
because
my friends,
despite the summit's images in which Kim
Jong Un almost looked like a cab app,
let's not forget who we really is.
Let's not forget that the North Korean
leader heads a regime of terror in which
human rights violations are part of the
state's routine function.
Cool.
Almost
forgotten the allegations that he had
his half brother with a chemical weapon
just last year and then he had his uncle
ripped apart with anti aircraft guns.
Gary Samore,
Obama's White House coordinator for arms
control and weapons of mass destruction.
In spite of that,
and thanks to the images we saw as the
declaration,
both governments agreed on most of the
press described this meeting as a
historic day,
the day when,
once and for all peace tribe.
All right,
so now the question really has to be,
well,
how true is all of this?
Are things really going that well?
In other words,
are we facing east sincere exercise in
diplomacy or simply a big marketing
scam?
Has Pyongyang roadmap actually changed?
Dialogue is certainly better than a
march to war.
That said,
we all need to keep our expectations in
check.
When Dr.
Sherman,
US Undersecretary of State for Political
Affairs from 2011 to 2015 and in North
Korea policy coordinator in the Clinton
administration,
we'll explore this,
but first here's a question that I'm
sure many of us have asked.
How the hell did we go in just a few
months from hearing the drums of war?
Have you got time
assumption?
Well cordio and harmonious meeting.
Okay,
well we can come up with three different
explanations.
That's still compliments.
The North Korean regime is new behavior,
which in a very short time it wins from
it threatening the United States to
suspending its nuclear and missile
tests.
Korea threatened to turn us into see a
flames.
North Korea says it will suspend nuclear
and missile tests.
So let's take a look at the possible
reasons for this change.
And let me tell you things are not as
simple as they seem.
Okay?
Pyongyang.
We have a problem.
Okay.
The first possible explanation,
according to several analysts from the
United States and South Korea in two
studies by Chinese researchers,
the Pong,
every nuclear tests sensor located in
the heart of a 2,200
meter high mountains in known as
mountains man's hap could have collapsed
after the last atomic test in which the
thermonuclear bomb of 250 kilos tons
with designated by North Korea and this
area on September the third 2017
yeah,
explosion was so strong that it calls
the 6.3
magnitude earthquake.
Well,
the collapse,
it seems to have been confirmed and it
isn't clear whether the center is
operational a lot based
on the severity of the initial blast,
the post test tremors and the extent of
observable surface disturbances,
we have to assume that there must have
been substantial damage to the existing
tunnel network under mount man tap,
Frank v,
pay Bian and Jack Lew.
If it isn't operational or if it's too
badly damaged,
it could take some time for the regime
to rebuild it enough to be able to hold
new tests in a safe manner.
This could have definitely been a factor
that could have altered the deadlines,
but it doesn't seem like this could have
been the main cause for the change of
discourse
economy's stupid.
Another hypothesis has to do with the
effects of international sanctions on
the North Korean economy.
As you all know,
North Korea is a very,
very poor country.
You see,
for years,
a large part of the international
community has imposed sanctions on North
Korea,
but these have generally not effective.
The country's main partners,
China,
Russia,
and Vietnam.
However,
all of this began to change with the
sanctions that the United Nations began
imposing on North Korea in 2017 in
response to its continued nuclear tests
for the first time,
these sanctions were greatly fulfilled
by China and that was a very hard blow
to North Korea.
The vast majority of North Korean trade
happens with China.
If that's cut well,
Pyongyang has a very serious
problem
multiplied when in September after the
last them a nuclear test,
the United Nations Security Council
bands,
all of North Korea's key exports
including coal,
iron and textiles.
This resolution is the single largest
economic sanctions package ever leveled
against the North Korean regime.
The price the North Korean leadership
will pay for its continued nuclear and
missile development will be the loss of
one third of its exports and hard
currency.
An old lady that was in December,
the same body agreed to limit their
refined oil imports do half a million
barrels per year,
a 90% reduction compared to the amount
of refined oil North Korea had purchased
over the previous year.
And what was the result of all of this?
Well,
several factories had to close due to a
lack of raw materials and the army due
to a lack of gasoline had to resort to
coal engines.
And even oxcarts.
And although it may surprise you,
this situation doesn't only accentuate
North Korea's weaknesses,
but it also is a hard blow to Kim Jong
Un's governments making economic
development's a big priority as of
course these sanctions are also
affecting the level of life the elite
sends the incipient middle class.
Enjoy.
Well,
hold on a moment.
So an emerging middle class in North
Korea.
Well yeah,
you had it right.
In fact,
here's a question for you.
Do you think they've,
a capitalist market can be developing
within present day North Korea?
Well,
stay tuned for an upcoming video that we
have on that.
Even though all of this is important and
to certainly influenced the situation,
it doesn't sound like something that
could put the regime at risk,
at least not for the moment.
You
think the North Koreans would revolt
where the regime would collapse because
of sanctions.
You don't know anything.
The North Koreans user,
people who survived the famine by eating
wheat came mission.
A North Korean defector who works for
South Korea's Essential Bank of Korea.
So then why is Pyongyang changed its
discourse so much?
Barb has it really just actually
changed.
North Korea is a nuclear power that is
simply a fax.
If according to American intelligence,
this country currently could have
between 20 and 60 warheads ready for use
stan.
Otherwise Pyongyang has already achieved
it's great goal.
It has its insurance,
it has the best deterrent that has ever
been built.
Now,
it is true that in the last April 27th
into Korea,
some is North Korea promise to
denuclearize the peninsula,
but Paul's on a moment because that
doesn't mean it's willing to give up its
nuclear weapons first because North
Korea has already promised many things
that they did and do.
For example,
the negotiations and agreements of 1991
1990 40,000
2007 2012 north grand promises not
exactly something new and so far they've
always been rather flimsy.
You see,
in 1994 Kim Jong UN's father Kim Jong Il
even went so far as to started
dismantling the nuclear program,
allowing international inspectors to
visit the country to verify the process.
This was all in exchange for some
generous health in the United States.
However,
years later the world found out that it
had been a scam.
The program had continued to developing
clandestinely.
Yeah.
In 2000 South Korean President Kim Die
Junge announced that a new day would
come after returning from his visit with
Kim Jong Il in Pyongyang in 2007 South
Korean President Romeo Horn stated
during his visit to North Korea,
Kim Jong Il has shown a will to restore
people.
And the second reason we can't assume
North Korea will give up its nuclear
weapons is that we may not be on the
same page about what constitutes
denuclearization allow me to explain for
beyond Yang.
This time has got a lot to do,
not only with its nuclear weapons,
but also with the u s military is
capabilities in the peninsula and in the
region.
And in any case,
the truth is that it seems very
difficult for Kim Jong Un to be willing
to part with his best life insurance.
We must remember,
North Korea is still North Korea.
Kim is still at the same person he was
when he purged potential rivals,
imprisoned thousands of his people and
had his relatives killed.
This was a hopeful moment,
but extreme caution as well.
Warranted Abraham Denmark,
director of the Asian program at the
Woodrow Wilson Center and former US
assistant secretary of defense for East
Asia.
In fact,
this is something that intercepted North
Korea.
Communications have definitely shown
everything seems to be part of some kind
of roadmap.
First,
ensure the survival of the regime,
something he has achieved with its
nuclear arsenal and seconds negotiate
with the international community to ends
the sanctions to launch a reform program
that can attract investment from China
and South Korea.
Yeah,
that means although far from how things
might seem at first to Pyongyang could
simply be following our well outlines
plan was the insecurity or some summit,
a big marketing exercise.
Then this in a way explains why South
Koreans,
it's so skeptical of the North's
promises.
I mean just check out this survey,
but now well it's your turn.
Do you think North Korea will actually
give up its nuclear program?
Leave your comments below and also in
this survey,
and they were really,
hope you enjoyed the video.
Please do hit that like button if you
did.
And don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for brand new videos every
Monday and every Thursday.
Also say,
don't forget to check it off.
Friends at the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this
episode,
but we're not mine.
And as always,
thank you for watching.
Hmm.